[Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  dr. Samuel 7 Oh No  well now to have dr. myself image  forever you know I usually mean some  [Music]  forest one what you feel for him a  Christmas young to listen to me you know  what this model India for soccer  oh uh turn off Danica afternoon and mr.  Dominic good to see you should have told  awfully sorry after I stopped or walk to  the Mart walks in and he's stabbing at  them in this we don't know  guilty' saluting surrounding the  appointed term our ceremony but but in  Davos  Barbossa general  oh I do  [Music]  humans are causing I mean our  linearization with you journey at  washing now only a do a Chaput  accountable only way to see the powerful  incredible islet you know this is on me  [Music]  you  [Music]